[Music]
in stop the fake news submitted by
kilims the courtier spreading fake news
on social media could become a crime in
Ireland hey that's pretty cool yeah
sometimes I'd be retweeting fake news
what about uh what about like thar the
newspaper things that those tabloids
that we have that are all fake you know
it sucks about me is just sometimes I
just like read stuff real quick right
delay hey man can you retweet this is
some serious [ __ ] going on I'm like I
retweet it I shouldn't do that I should
be looking at it to see if it's real
yeah you're spreading yeah but the pump
with that is it requires work so I just
want to be a good person on like the
Klan's
yeah but I'm not doing that anymore
because the last thing i retweeted was a
little fake fake what was it it was
something it was that girl who yeah
so I [ __ ] up on that real quick
Rihanna and everybody was retweeting
that [ __ ] and then I just saw oh yeah
and I didn't hear the whole story about
what happened all I saw was rape yeah
little girl and I was like Bri tweet I
don't think so
finally the whole story I called a flag
behind it which was okay because of
mother yeah still good intentions yeah I
good intentions but bad results even the
news on TV they have some kind of fake
knows about a story on Jake a news but
then we try not to give you guys fake
news if we know that it's it's fake yeah
we try not to do it if we know that it's
fake and so there's some times we're
like oh I just found out that that thing
is fake and then we don't do it I'm not
gonna trust them because they told us
that there's weapons of mass destruction
in Iraq and there isn't the media from
mm yep Oh
when I was in high school and I saw that
[ __ ] and it didn't happen I was like I
know what you did [ __ ] you just wanted
to get oil you think I'm stupid huh I'm
17 but I know I know you want it oil
exactly so you're probably a 9/11
conspirator as well I don't know about
that all I'm saying is that there was no
reason to go inside Iraq no reason but
oil well saleh wasn't hanging out there
why the [ __ ] are we going in there it
don't make no sense
so the news said hey American people
we're gonna make these guys the demons
so Bush and his Texaco can go up in
there and [ __ ] take all the oil
that's why [ __ ] mm mm I'll remember
[ __ ] CNN all you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you die slow [ __ ]
all your kids don't grow housing anyone
she doesn't like no that was 1994 was it
Tupac I quote from hit him up no the
whole event I'm sorry I'm sorry
1969 later I got a little excited I'm
sorry i I'm just despaired a possum I
decide you man sorry
[ __ ] I think the Philippines and I can
speak on behalf
I think the Philippines could benefit
from a law like that I think they are
the master of perpetuating fake news I
am and I think that it's very
detrimental to a third world country
like that because just the masses in
general like the people living in the
province who aren't so like savvy with
the Internet they're more prone to
believing these things including like
someone like my mom who's an educated
person but because she's not like
familiar with Facebook or how like media
has presented these days she looks at
like an article that looks seemingly
real and she's like oh yeah that's
that's real that has to be real they're
pictures they're it's you know it's
formatted this way is this before or
after she's pumping water from a hole
you can we show that video please I feel
like Asian parents right if they read it
in a newspaper if they heard from a
friend those two things it defeats
scientific evidence if my friend told me
that shits be on evidence and facts yeah
Arthur's camera yeah like I'm pretty
sure my parents would be flat earthers
if their friends told them that the
earth was flat
dude [ __ ] Korean newspapers ruined my
life as a kid [ __ ] my dad would mean
anything on that [ __ ] and it was just
truth this will beat my ass cuz he told
me that it's impossible for me to go to
a college if I don't get a perfect 1600
on SATs other words read that Korean
newspaper always got my ass beat because
of that [ __ ] oh there was this huge fan
of Korea we're drinking pee was great
too because of the Korean newspaper
Koreans are gullible as hell because my
best friend is Korean and one time I
told her that she couldn't do a sit-up
with her eyes closed but it was like
physically and humanly impossible but
you were just trolling so she was like
she's one of those like super
competitive people she's like I could
[ __ ] do that [ __ ] hmm
so she closed her eyes to do this setup
and I spread my ass cheeks stinky tofu
[ __ ]
walking around like that it's funny I
keep you know I don't I should have said
that in another video this one just came
out weird awesome to watch wouldn't want
a some iOS girl in here so they're
proposing a new law where it would be a
crime to spread fake news if they caught
you with those automatic automatic BOTS
that just spread all of these like fake
news then you would be you could be
punishable in prison up to five years
that's dope I like that thank you lucky
charms you are a mother [ __ ] awesome
it's really good
because they're saying like the
lawmakers they are being has speculated
with the whole 2016 US election how the
Russians and the whole like fake news
really swayed the election and also the
whole brexit vote because there was a
lot of fake news that swayed people to
get out of the EU and so they're just
saying like we don't want that [ __ ]
happening in Ireland so if we catch
anyone that has BOTS they're going to
prison yeah I like that they should just
die just get killed Irish people are
just the fair skinned versions of Korean
people
what cuz they're angry they're angry
magician to oppress the press people yes
I'm saying I wasn't going to go that
deep you smartest [ __ ] I was thinking
about I was just thinking about the beer
and the [ __ ] fighting yeah we'd like
to drink a lot and we [ __ ] fight a
lot yeah that's all I know I'm very very
quick to anger mmm you drink [ __ ]
fight or [ __ ] fight oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] fibro okay fine I got it
I thought drink [ __ ] and fight no pretty
boy - angry - sex they get sleepy after
the gangrene yeah but they're also
mentioning here that they'll be like if
it that so the whole five year in prison
thing would be if it's like high level
that would be a high level punishment
but then low level punishments it would
be like six months in jail or like a six
hundred dollar fine what's low level
punishments for like you could tell like
Oh a new species of squirrels are moving
into town and it's not this really
affect anyone then you get that but then
if you tell something that's really out
of like national scale then you get in
big trouble
I think it's more if you're trying to
sway people in like what can I get away
with yeah I think it's more like trying
to just weigh people in a political
sense
oh I hope parity is safe from this I'm
pretty sure that's going to be because I
mean like the I more taking comedy so
serious these days like you're not
supposed to take it serious it's
supposed to be stupid I hate this [ __ ]
why do you take comedy suit
I don't understand yeah and I don't know
how like why do you give me a voice I
don't understand man this is stupid you
don't want to have a voice no I just
want to talk and like you know like
let's let's play with the fun let's
let's just play with the hypothetical
you know but then it's like when you
take it from the [ __ ] dream world
into the reality world and then you take
what I say a hundred percent to your
soul then you're the [ __ ] idiot
Matt mean because you're if you're
listening to an idiot then you're
[ __ ] stupid you think the blame is
like on the English teachers where
people don't speak English well enough
or you think it's like at home where the
parents are teaching the kids how to
receive information maybe it's because
the pears are just a bunch of [ __ ]
and they just [ __ ] just just don't
know how to take a joke either
and so their kids don't know how to take
a [ __ ] joke and so their kids become
[ __ ] sensitive yeah and so it's just
a bunch of [ __ ] floppy dics and
[ __ ] all over the place we're like
terminally unfunny where they just they
just do not have a sense of humor or
imaginative yeah they can't imagine that
any information they receive could like
make make them giggle like some people
are just [ __ ] duds
isn't that called Asperger's all and
they take everything literally yeah like
you can't I think it's even worse
actually budgetary sarcasm because some
you can't read those emotions yeah
everything is literal because some
people will be like hey imagine your
kids on fire or like imagine you're on
fire oh oh my god why would you say that
I would never want to be like I said
imagine yeah oh you think Asperger's I
thought you said Asbergers I just can't
pronounce it how do you pronounce it the
proper way
just right I just asked my girls yeah
it's the opposite of that right and so
like one is like two logical and not
sensitive at all
yeah but then what's the other one the
hypersensitive one that even they can't
even play with the hypothetical is that
the because emphasize that happy or they
are they impact
and actually can't empathize because you
go can you imagine this and they can't
even put themselves in that situation to
examine it from a different person oh
they they put it in so much the point
where they see the burning child and
they go oh no I can't even imagine that
oh it's too much yeah it's too much not
too much in front of a car please too
much imagination that's that's kind of
you know what I do have a cousin that
can't even watch like roadrunner type of
violence oh sure meat meat that guy yeah
like a piano following falling on a
cartoon
come on experience drama
oh she's like what like in her 40s but
yeah her dad was super abusive so any
any any sign of aggression hit trigger
any type of even if it's like like a
cartoon that's when buying buying boy
[ __ ] like super sensitive I love she
costs like a County Fair people are
shooting like teddy bears down this is
like for hunting I wouldn't be surprised
and she saw that [ __ ] and she was like
oh I can't pluck a snake
did I [ __ ] love aggression aggression
is one of my favorite things on earth I
watch three nights max
I watched I watched three fights to go
to sleep it's [ __ ] tight you know
those [ __ ] when they catch an MMA
fighter I love that [ __ ] [ __ ] dude I
can't do that anymore it brings me to a
bad place
I'm trying to be more Zen these days
dude I'm not suppressing it but I'm
trying to control this I want to feel
more relaxed I want to be like a
dandelion in the morning just [ __ ]
opening up like this I don't want to be
like somebody that wakes up in the
morning and wants to bite somebody in
the neck rip their [ __ ] throat out
put my hand inside grab their [ __ ]
heart put it on my plate and eat that
[ __ ] for breakfast I don't want to do
that with like Bruce Banner bro I want
to relax please
please I just want to be a dandelion
just blow me and I [ __ ] go into the
wind that's a little too sexual Pro Tony
Beck where is that sexual I just want
someone to blow I just wanna blow my eye
I saw like a ballet like I was a
ballerina just spinning and twirling
like I was like that [ __ ] you know
you blew two you know that Chinese
ballet shoe that Shen moon and should
plane everywhere I said that I saw that
[ __ ] in France I saw that [ __ ]
international yeah we saw last year
everywhere I think we were like in Italy
or something and I'm like what the [ __ ]
[Music]
looks horrible I heard it was for sure
someone I know went to it and they said
it was really good I grew up going on
shows like that my mom and they were
born as [ __ ]
what if it's like Chinese Cirque
I know what you're talking about though
because like I feel like my sense of
entertainment when it comes to those
things is on your level because when I
see that I'm like well great getting a
job somewhere else [ __ ] I don't know
what that's the only thing I think mind
you if I see two people cage fighting I
see skill of that skill level two
it says who gives a [ __ ] it's what I
think if there's 50 Chinese people on a
bicycle that are spinning plates
that's the carpool lane that's that's a
normal day in Vietnam did I call it a
Saigon taxi
[Music]
[Music]